the glimmer of hope for Africa it's sort
of like the good things the bad things
are racing each other to see which gets
the upper hand the good thing is that
you have more countries that have a
decent sustained growth rate four or
five six seven percent and I think
that's actually connected to democracy
most of those countries are countries
that have democratized the really high
growth countries there are the
autocracies that have oil like Angola
which grows it like twenty percent a
year so that's the positive stuff at the
same time these are really weak states
and so when they face a crisis like aids
they don't have the public health
structure to do anything about it very
effectively the landlocked countries in
Africa almost never have an internal
transportation system that allows them
to bring goods to market at affordable
prices so these infrastructure problems
that almost all African countries have
are just they're just they're huge and
they can wind up being powerful enough
to counteract all those positive forces
so there's not there are some reasons
for optimism but really tempered
optimism
you